más impuestos sobre las rentas más altas
y sus fortunas así como una subida de
las contribuciones sobre las empresas
más grandes son las medidas de las que
presume el presidente del gobierno de
españa pedro sánchez y su vice
presidente pablo iglesias una coalición
de izquierdas que busca un aumento de
tres puntos porcentuales sobre las
rentas de capital que superen la barrera
de los 200 mil euros anuales uno de dos
puntos sobre las rentas de trabajo que
superen la barrera de los 300 mil euros
anuales y una subida de un punto sobre
los impuestos de fuerte unas mayores a
los 10 millones de euros estos son unos
presupuestos inaplazables no son unos
presupuestos indispensables para la
modernización y la recuperación de
nuestra economía son unos presupuestos
progresistas y son los presupuestos a
nuestro juicio que nuestro país necesita
presupuestos progresistas que en lo que
se refiere a las rentas afectarán sólo a
17.000 personas de un país de 46
millones de habitantes pero que el
vicepresidente ve como un primer paso
hoy inauguramos una nueva época en la
política económica en españa una nueva
época que deja atrás definitivamente la
etapa neoliberal de la austeridad y de
los recortes en lo público
196 mil 97 millones de euros de
presupuesto para gasto con un 10 por
ciento más para inversión pública
respecto a la partida anterior y con 27
mil millones de euros de fondos europeos
para paliar la crisis del cob y 19 todo
esto en un país cuyo producto interno
bruto está previsto que caiga más de un
11% este año con un desempleo del 16,2
por ciento en el tercer trimestre y un
déficit que llegaría el 11,3 por ciento
a final de año ahora viene la difícil
aprobación en el congreso en donde el
gobierno necesitará aliarse con otras
fuerzas para sacar adelante su propuesta
y busca conseguir la aprobación al
completo de unos presupuestos anuales
por primera vez desde 2016